on this thursday night a mask
milestone in the u.s we have
all longed for this moment who has to
wear masks and who doesn't
the new guidelines for fully vaccinated
americans
an alberta oil sands worker and father
of eight fighting for his life
my husband was so close to being
vaccinated
plus ontario extends its stay-at-home
order
and end of the road greyhound is
shutting down in canada the bus
company's
slow death and free burgers cold beer
or cold hard cash anything we can do to
get the jabs in people's arms i think is
great
the incentives to get inoculated
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with a momentous decision in
the u.s and a sign of what life could be
like when people are fully vaccinated
the u.s centers for disease control has
released new guidance
on masks with some caveats it's now says
those who are fully vaccinated can stop
wearing masks indoors and outdoors
if you are fully vaccinated you can
start doing the things that you had
stopped
doing because of the pandemic we have
all longed for this moment that moment
has come
for those who are fully vaccinated
it is a huge step in a country where
almost 600 000 people have died of covet
19 and where they are still dying almost
600 deaths
were reported on average every day in
the last week
there are big questions too about how
people will prove they're vaccinated and
who will enforce it
our washington bureau chief jackson
prescoe is with me jackson this
is big news so big the president came
out to talk about it without wearing a
mask
why did the cdc do this today well donna
in short it's because they feel
it's finally safe to do so here in the
u.s 250 million vaccine doses have been
given out in just the past
114 days that covers almost 60 percent
of adults with at least one shot
while 45 of adult americans are now
fully vaccinated
compare that to just 3.5 percent of
canadians who are fully vaccinated
you can see the huge difference there
and with cases and deaths plummeting in
the u.s the cdc says
it's safe for those fully vaccinated
individuals to take off their masks
stop social distancing even indoors now
of course there are exceptions namely
planes
trains and buses which will likely still
require masks until the fall
and it's not clear how long individual
cities and states will keep their local
mass mandates in place
or how private businesses will react
knowing that there are still a lot of
unvaccinated people out there
the rule is very simple get vaccinated
or wear a mask until you do
it's not an enforcement thing we're not
going to go out and arrest people
i still believe the vast majority of the
american people
care about the safety of their neighbors
the natural question of course is how do
you tell who's vaccinated
while americans have been given cdc
vaccination cards
it's doubtful they'll be required to
show them there's no need for a
so-called
vaccine passport yet instead the cdc is
stressing the risk of going masculine to
those who
are unvaccinated and donna they're
hoping that showing all the normal
things that are possible with
vaccination
will be enough to encourage those who
are still on the fence to get their
shots
donna interesting strategy jackson
prosco in washington
thanks canada is making progress on
vaccinations but we're nowhere close to
having the majority of people fully
vaccinated
and federal public health officials said
today don't expect
relaxed masking rules here anytime soon
i would certainly say that for something
like the face mask i would say that
would be uh
probably one of the last things to go i
think it's just a good practice to keep
on right into the fall
in bc and ontario more than 50 percent
of eligible people have now received one
dose and in both provinces the numbers
of daily new cases is dropping
today ontario premier doug ford says it
is too soon though
to lift the provincial stay-at-home
order he has extended it
to june second we need to do everything
in our power
to protect this summer for all ontarians
my goal is to have the most normal july
and august possible
ontario's top doctor says cases must be
well below 1 000 per day before the
stay-at-home order can be lifted
today the province recorded more than
2700 new infections
alberta has had the most active daily
cases per capita for weeks now and it
still does
including outbreaks in the oil sands
tonight we hear from one woman whose
husband became ill with kobit 19 while
working at an oil sands camp
the 51 year old father of eight is now
fighting for his life
heather urex west has his story
it was an opportunity this alberta woman
says her husband could not afford to
turn down
this job was important to our family
as coveted resulted in
my husband's place of work being shut
down
over a year ago so in march he headed to
camp
taking a job at cnrl horizon one of
thousands of tradespeople brought in by
the company
to help with maintenance something the
industry calls a turnaround
the site had been in an active outbreak
since october but when the additional
workers arrived on site in april
the virus began spreading fast a month
later hundreds of workers had become
sick on april 23rd the father of eight
learned
he was positive as well so immediately
he was put in
to isolation at their isolation wing at
camp far from family his wife could only
check on her husband with phone calls
and texts
but after seven days she said it became
clear her husband
was very ill i was just very concerned
when
when he was able to speak only one in
two word answers so i asked him to
please call for medical help because he
hadn't received
medical check-ins physical check-ins for
seven
days at that point that night he was
taken to hospital in fort mcmurray
infected with the p1 variant from brazil
he is now in the cardiac intensive care
unit at edmonton's u of a
hospital fighting for his life because
he accepted a job
what we are seeing unfortunately is the
impact of some of the variants of
concern
as in many other places in the province
we have seen transmission
increase when variants of concern are
introduced workers are now being offered
vaccinations on site the province hoping
immunizations will help
bring these outbreaks under control soon
little comfort for the thousands already
infected
and those watching loved ones struggle
to survive
heather yorick's west global news
calgary
internal discontent over premier jason
kenney's leadership has boiled over into
an open
challenge the caucus chair of the united
conservative party in alberta has quit
in a letter posted on facebook mla todd
lowen says
he's lost confidence in kenny and asks
him to resign
lowen is one of 18 back bench members to
push back against the restrictions kenny
imposed in april which they believe
infringe on personal freedoms he writes
we did not unite around blind loyalty to
one man
and while you promoted unity it is clear
that unity
is falling apart lowen will stay in the
party but says he's resigned as caucus
chair so he can
speak freely another sign of the times
today greyhound canada is shutting down
all of its remaining bus routes
permanently
it had cut routes in western canada
three years ago
now it's pulling out of the entire
country mike armstrong
explains why it was one year ago to the
day
greyhound canada announced it was due to
the pandemic
suspending service well on that
anniversary
it is making it permanent the
announcement on the greyhound canada
website quotes a senior vice president
stuart kendrick says a full year without
revenue
has unfortunately made it impossible to
continue operations
it's a bit of a bit of a shocker bus
travelers have been forced for a year to
find alternatives like the train
alternatives that are often more
expensive less option
less option is no good according to the
company they've been losing money in
canada since 2004.
three years ago it shut down operations
in western canada the old calgary
station is vaccination center today
well covet 19 was the final blow i think
it accelerated it
transportation expert david duvall calls
the death of greyhound canada
sad but not surprising it was a service
he says that could no longer be
profitable based only on fares
if governments see a value or an
importance in the service they'll have
to subsidize it he says
or set up a new one the biggest impact
of all says won't be in the big cities
where there are options
but in between in smaller communities
those are the towns that are
thinking well what's going to happen now
to
our accessibility and our connectivity
to
wider social health and economic
networks that we need
in a statement the federal transport
minister said thursday the government
quote will work with our provincial
partners to explore
options to address this gap now some
canadians will see greyhound buses
post-pandemic
they just won't be canadian the american
greyhound
company will be running buses to and
from the u.s
to vancouver montreal and toronto
mike armstrong global news montreal
a coroner's inquest has begun into the
death of joyce eshequan the indigenous
woman who was subjected to racist
insults in a quebec hospital the video
she took at that time is disturbing
eshequan was crying out in pain as staff
insulted and mocked her
the 37 year old mother of seven died
shortly after posting this
today her husband told the inquest she
didn't deserve to have her life end that
way
the family's lawyer hopes the inquiry
will prompt concrete changes
did george receive the health care that
was required by her condition
at the time of her death and was
racism how did racism
inform the decisions that were taken
the inquest will hear from about 50
witnesses including health care staff
the federal ethics commissioner has
finished his investigation into the we
charity controversy and has concluded
prime minister justin
trudeau did not break any conflict of
interest rules but the former finance
minister did
our chief political correspondent david
aiken has the details
david well donna trudeau is calling it a
win but the pm's political opponents say
his role in the we charity scandal still
stinks
ethics commissioner mario dion found
trudeau did not
advance either his own or his family's
interests
when his government decided to award the
we charity
a contract worth more than 40 million
dollars to run a pandemic
emergency program to provide 900 million
dollars in grants
to post-secondary students and in making
that conclusion
dion cleared trudeau of ethics
violations in the wii scandal
trudeau had no public events thursday
but in a statement he said
this confirms what i've been saying from
the beginning my job as prime minister
is to do whatever it takes for as long
as it takes by providing direct support
to people and businesses
to get through this not so says the
opposition
they breached ethics to help their
friends and it hurt students
because students still haven't received
the billion dollars promise to help them
out
prime minister trudeau himself said he
was in a conflict of interest
in the wii scandal a perception of
conflict of interest
his family was paid family members were
paid half a million dollars and he was
involved in a decision of a non-tendered
contract worth hundreds of millions of
dollars to those people who paid his
family
trudeau's former finance minister bill
morneau was found to have violated the
conflict of interest law
after dion determined we charity
founders craig and mark kielburger
were legally friends of moreno's and
morneau's actions were judged
to have advanced their interests
commissioner dion's findings come with
no penalty there's no fines
just another black mark on mourinho's
time in office now despite the ruling in
trudeau's favor
his opponents want to make the wii
charity matter
another ethics black mark against
trudeau to go with his
other two ethics violations the ogacon
vacation in the bahamas
and the snc lavaland matter donna
all right david thanks
the escalating crisis in the middle east
coming up rockets mob violence and late
tonight israeli ground troops move into
gaza
there has been another serious
escalation in the violence between
israel and gaza
just after midnight local time the
israeli army sent ground forces and
tanks
into gaza warning people within four
kilometers of the border to stay in
shelters
and there are reports israeli airstrikes
are intensifying
diplomatic efforts are underway to try
to de-escalate things but
hours before moving into gaza israel
called up 7 000 military reservists
and there's been mob violence on the
streets in towns where arabs and
israelis have long lived in peace
eric sorenson reports
it was anticipated and now israeli
ground troops have entered gaza
a major escalation up to now missiles
had been sent into gaza city
overnight and again in the morning
targeting the hamas military
those civilian casualties too are
climbing and today a massive funeral
procession for hamas commanders
just across the border israelis could
see hamas rockets lifting off from gaza
life is anything but normal here
in loud cafe patrons scattered as bombs
fell
just missing this apartment and israelis
too mourn the dead
[Applause]
but there is a disturbing turn in towns
like lord where jews and arabs have
coexisted peacefully
protests by israeli arabs turned violent
this week
this jewish man says a mob attacked his
car a local synagogue was burned
but in another town a car driven by an
arab was blocked
the driver pulled and beaten by jewish
rioters
it was never like this says this jewish
resident
his friend adding we need to live here
together
one analyst says the causes of the
unrest run deep
towns and cities that have once been
pretty much peaceful
bastions of coexistence are now blowing
up with
direct hand-to-hand combat what i would
say is that there's an ongoing
systemic issue of oppression of
palestinian
citizens diplomatic efforts have so far
achieved little they want to see
de-escalation they want to see both
sides
sitting down talking through and
stopping the violence
what we do mean now is diplomacy this is
the incredibly
sad thing while politics is being played
and missiles are being thrown back and
forth there are people on the ground
children mothers fathers on both sides
being killed
israel's prime minister elbow-bumped
israeli soldiers today
he said we continue striking hamas and
added it will
take more time it's clear now what
netanyahu meant as troops gathered on
the gaza border
and late thursday night israel sent its
military into gaza
eric sorensen global news toronto
the garretts and the michaels still
ahead the links between two stories of
canadians detained in china
global news is launching a new series
called china rising the podcast will
examine how the chinese government is
allegedly targeting canada and its
allies
deploying a range of tactics including
hostage diplomacy
the most famous examples of canadians
being held in china are of course
michael spavor and michael kovrig
but they aren't the only canadians who
have been caught in the political
crossfire
jeff semple spoke to julia and kevin
garrett about their experience
and their advice to others
for nearly two and a half years the two
michaels have remained
out of reach canadian spavor and kovrig
accused by beijing of spying their
trials held behind
closed doors their ordeal difficult to
even imagine
but not for julia and kevin garrett our
situation is very similar to the
michaels
the canadian couple lived in china for
three decades before their arrest in
2014
accused of spying following the arrest
of a chinese suspect
in canada at the request of the united
states the garretts were held in
separate cells
interrogated for six hours every day
they threatened execution many times
they each kept diaries in john 15.
kevin wrote bible verses about hope
while julia scribbled pictures of
anything she was grateful for
like i heard a bird outside i heard like
some chirping of a bird so i drew like a
few birds
because the other alternative is you get
lost in
bitterness anger rage and i knew that
wasn't a good choice but as the months
dragged on
their notes grew darker like you get
into this more
deep deep despair after seven months
julia was released
but not kevin like the michaels his
trial was also closed to the public
which he believes is actually a positive
if it was a public trial meaning there
are spectators
it will not go away they're going to
make an example of you
kevin was later convicted of spying but
unbeknownst to him
political relations were warming the
chinese suspect in canada
suddenly pleaded guilty and prime
minister trudeau visited
china amid talk of a possible trade deal
two weeks later kevin was released
reunited with his family
the garretts say the government's quiet
backdoor diplomacy
helped to secure their release so their
approach was
extremely diplomatic and so it wasn't in
the media
they're doing it differently with the
two michaels uh some quiet action but
more
in the news and in in their face but
even when it seems
insurmountable their story is a reminder
of how quickly the winds
can change i think i would say you hold
on
it will not last forever jeff semple
global news toronto
you can listen to china rising on apple
podcast spotify
amazon music or wherever you get your
favorite podcasts
a jab for the jackpot next some million
dollar incentives to get vaccinated
you can get a vaccine at the game
new york governor andrew cuomo is
offering a perk for baseball fans get
vaccinated at clinics set up at mets and
yankees games and you not only get
protected you'll get a free ticket to
another game most americans under the
age of 65 are not vaccinated yet and
there's a big push on to fix that
easing the rules about masks for fully
vaccinated americans is one incentive
jackson proskow explains some others
did you say free fries when you get
vaccinated
i got vaccinated from free burgers and
fries to donuts and beer there you go
the push to encourage vaccination has
turned into a personalized sales pitch
anything we can do to get the jabs in
people's arms i think is great
so some states are paying people to get
the vaccine
50 dollars in parts of texas 100 savings
bonds in west virginia
and then there's ohio where you can get
a shot and win a lot
that first number up tonight is seven
five one million dollar prizes
in a special lottery for the fully
vaccinated you have the other group of
people though
who are not vaccinated and the danger to
them is even more
great in some respects than it has been
in the past because this variant
is more contagious canadians are getting
a taste of it
even if they can't yet get their second
shots montreal-based acom
timber will pay employees 350
once they're fully vaccinated the
university of lethbridge is giving away
free tuition to nine students who get
their first shot by september
we are very committed to doing
everything we can
to make sure that we create a safe and
healthy environment
in the fall and vaccinations are part of
that
you don't address vaccine hesitancy by
buying compliance
some epidemiologists question the ethics
of it all believing social incentives
promoting a return to normal
are better get vaccinated you can do all
these wonderful things like hug your
loved ones and be in your room
without math and go to the theater et
cetera and when the toronto blue jays
play their
home opener in buffalo new york fans
will get a grand slam of that kind of
encouragement
a special section without distancing for
the fully vaccinated
and free shots in the stadium for those
who still need them
jackson proskow global news washington
and that is global national for this
thursday i'll say goodbye tonight
wishing eid mubarak to muslims in canada
and around the world who are celebrating
the end of the holy month of ramadan
we leave you tonight with some images of
eid prayers and
celebrations from around the globe
thanks for watching